the wait is finally over if you haven't
heard by now rocket League is finally
available for Xbox one psionics popular
soccer with cars game released last
summer for PlayStation 4 in PC and can
now be purchased for twenty dollars on
Microsoft's console additionally the
developers announced that the game has
reached 11 million downloads across
playstation 4 in pc the xbox one version
includes the base game and previous
released expansions including supersonic
fury revenge of the battle cars and
chaos run xbox one owners will also get
some exclusive cars and accessories to
go along with them the two exclusive
cars are halos warthog and gears of wars
armadillo the extra accessories include
wheels antennas and rocket trails from
halo Gears of War and sunset overdrive
but if a delorean equipped to the flux
capacitor is more your style then you'll
be happy to know that you can also pick
up rocket leagues Back to the Future car
pack for two bucks in other rocket
League news the developer just released
a new rocket labs playlist which allows
players to try out new arenas before
they release into competitive modes for
more on rocket League stay tuned to
gamespot